[Music]
so you guys know how on this show we
talk a lot about
how like canadians are tend to be very
very very polite
right yes that's like the stereotype of
canadian that's what they're known for
like syrup
maple syrup very sweet people sweet like
they're maple syrup exactly
sweet eh so i have a story here that
just like i feel
is just like the most canadian thing
that you can do as a canadian person so
this woman
she was arrested and she spent several
days in police custody
and after she was sent home or like
after she was released or whatever
she sent a homemade thank you card to
her jailers
oh [ __ ] and she even reviewed them and
gave them a 4.5 stars
on yelp no in the car oh okay could they
have done better
that's true and how many jails has she
been in
that this was a 4.5 compared to exactly
i was in toronto but
hands down vancouver you guys are the
[ __ ] man
toronto they're [ __ ] up yeah is it the
monty's aren't
do do they ride horses not that i know
of
or moose oh man that could be good
mounties on the moose
yeah not that i know of but this is what
the card looks like
handmade and it says if for some reason
our airplane was experiencing problems
i would help you with your oxygen mask
before adjusting mine
wow that's what the cover says but
that's not how it works though you're
supposed to protect yourself so you can
yeah yeah because if you pass out so
she's responsible
she had made it and then on the inside
it looks like this and then i'll read it
all right well the parts of the card
says and that's and that's against guy
code
she knows but then her handwritten part
says
i was nervous about staying with you
guys during my trip to the island
but i wanted to let you know that i
appreciated how helpful and kind
everyone was
especially the four jailers who do a
tough job and are often
underappreciated by the people in their
care oh you make a difference
heart and then it says west shore rcmp
which is the jail
and then it says thank you for your care
and kindness
while i was in your custody smiley face
and then it says four and a half stars
winky face at the bottom
what if she got released for doing like
30 years and and because she just
murdered someone
right she just split a guy's throat no i
know what kind of intense jail that is
this it's on an island
apparently like alcatraz oh yeah what
did she do
so you know we have this image of
canadia being like this like super
peaceful awesome place right
um my professor like when i was taking
psychology he's a canadian and he worked
at a
insane asylum out there and um
he said that the patients there were
some guys that were just like
pretty much like serial killer kind of
thing i thought you're gonna say they're
major huggers
no but he was like it's because this is
all happening in canada and you don't
expect these kind of things to go down
but like he's like those patients in the
insane asylum they were so rude
and all right no he would he went to one
of the uh like one of his
patients there the reason why he's in
there is because well this is the nice
part but i'll get to that
but he he went up to a house and he
knocked on the door
and he's like can i use your bathroom
and they're like [ __ ] off right
which is not very canadian right and
then so he's like okay so he went into
the barn
he got some barbed wire he opened the
door again and then he wrapped it around
the guy's neck
and basically choked them out with it
and then he walked into the police
station and this is the nice part he was
like yeah i killed somebody
and then he went you know he was he was
administered
but uh i was like damn what a nice
killer
it's a nicer version of a killer he
turned himself in
no that but he wasn't nice to the other
guy he probably apologized as he was
doing it sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry i just wanted to use the
potty yeah
what did she do crazy so i don't know
and the jail won't say
what she did because then it would it
would give clues as to who she is and
she's trying to be anonymous
so they're not trying to like reveal
something bad then
something very unique yeah very unique i
guess for protecting your privacy i
suppose
biggest maple syrup heist in the history
of canadia
at the beginning of the card almost
sounded like they had like a fivesome or
something
like you four jailers just banged me so
good that would be a pretty good
porno that's what it sounded like jail
porno is always interesting because they
always have to have a scene where a guy
sticks his dick
between the bars and then they have to
suck it on the other side
i saw that on on ratchet oh okay on
ratchet what's that
uh the netflix show with sarah paulson
oh you can see penis on the netflix show
i don't know if you saw a penis but
there was a character who stuck his dick
through the bars and then he got a
[ __ ]
yeah that's so it does work yeah i guess
it's like a glory bar not a glory hole
yeah it's definitely not a glory hole
because you could see everything
but they do have it's a good placement
to hold while you're getting sucked that
is pretty cool yeah i never thought
about it
i don't know how uncomfortable it is to
stick your dick through a glory hole
yeah
because your face is smushed against the
wall normally well you don't do it like
that you gotta do it like this you can't
wear a hat you gotta you gotta
yeah you gotta put your cheek on and you
gotta put your hands on the wall no
good tips i need to write this down yeah
that's true it depends how
how how wide they are like the spaces in
between the bars because
you could probably fit like your face
dude we should get a glory hole expert
to come in for that that's what we
should do
like you may you might not recognize me
like this but maybe like this
[Laughter]
a jailer or a glory hole expert both
both and then we can have the mask
together and
where would you find this glory hole
expert oh come on where do you even find
the adult video store and you start
asking questions where do you find glory
holes have you ever seen one in person
no of course not they're all in bar
stove
i don't know i assume every rest stop
has those we do
yeah every one of those truck rest stops
i feel like just put one through that
rest top bathroom but that's because of
movies and tv mainly i don't i've never
seen one me neither
so then what's usually on the other side
a mouth or a butthole or a mouth
hopefully mouth you hope it's not a
butthole i know
you just never know what you're gonna
get
that's funny there might be two men's
room who knows oh yeah
a lot of it is i thought it was from
that i think it came from a lot of that
yeah i thought it was guys with guys it
was like repressed
like um like religious people who like
did it anonymously so it didn't feel as
bad so glory hole was a
was a men and men sex kind of thing
that's what i always heard
i watched i watched the clint eastwood
movie and i and i that's what my
understanding was
well the ones i see usually stars a lady
with many different cultures
that go through the hole and they're
really [ __ ] hot too right
you think any of them ever stop halfway
through and they're like you're not very
good at this i'm gonna turn around and
stick it in the other hole
oh there's multiple holes both sides
hold a lot of competition in that
particular
yeah that's good though that keeps the
girls working hard it's like a
whack-a-mole but with dicks
so is there like a little money slot or
in my scenario they're making money
after this or
no it's all it's all it's all because
they want to do it they they
put their whole heart into their
performance i don't think they do it for
charity i think they're paid actors
but that's just my take on it and the
real ones or the pornos i didn't know
there were real ones that's why i'm kind
of confused
like when steve was talking about they
used to do this like in real life
so they still do i assume but there's a
clint eastwood movie i saw where they
had this
in it and i was like oh [ __ ] what
happened in the movie it was in the 70s
uh clint eastwood was an undercover cop
and he like infiltrated
like a part of the gay community to find
like a serial killer it was pretty good
because i was like i didn't see that in
gran torino but yeah no not in here
all the asian gangs a lot a lot of uh
it's like dang man well i missed that
scene dude i didn't see
that yeah you never saw that movie i
hear it's really good
have you guys ever been to like a hostel
like in europe i don't think they got
glory holes though do they
i don't know i just always think of like
these shady sexual places
and i don't see them because i'm not
like
going into these parts but i am
interested in the red light district
yeah i've been to red light it's just to
walk through but i've never
seen like but that's also kind of like
like mainstream like that's something
that's like part of their tourism you
know i'm talking about like the more
like underbelly of parts like like which
gas station are you gonna find the glory
hole at
all that's like someone you need to know
in that area to be like
take me to these local remember i i told
you guys i went to that sex shop to buy
some condoms
like that kind of place and i was like
oh it's a special video store
but there's a lot of guys coming in and
out of the rooms
you never asked i don't want to it was
scary
there was no noises coming from the
rooms was there ah maybe they finished
fast
or they were soundproof can i ask like
is that
anything that you guys ever thought like
okay maybe
a group of guys like all the bachelors
like all single or whatever and then i
want to go
check places out like this in my area or
when we go
on a trip as a guy like let's go find
something like this but the one that i
went to
they were um they weren't ladies
why were you confused with the whole
like glory hole then if
you were literally there you were there
no but it wasn't a glory hole
it was like what a biker gang name it
was i know i think it was a brothel
oh i think it was like a like a like a
sex ring
like i don't like glory holes like when
you stick a dick in the wall
i mean i didn't know that well that's
what you assume it is
what the stick a dick through a wall we
don't really know that is a brothel
it could have been stick and digging
okay so what i witnessed
was a uh transgender sex brothel
yeah so that's why i was shocked because
i was like
wait first of all brothels are illegal
and
i didn't even know what was happening
because everything was just like
what the [ __ ] aren't they legal or
something in vegas cause don't they have
a bunny ranch in vegas i wasn't in vegas
no it's in nevada but
not legal in vegas oh okay no for some
reason i thought you were talking about
in vegas
no but that's what i'm talking about
because these things are
everywhere yeah you just gotta know
where to go but yeah that's what i was
thinking because it was like a um
it was like everyone there knew except
me
like it's like it's one of those places
where it's like you don't go there
to actually buy lingerie condoms and
like
like it's not a real adult store that
was the front
that's when i was like oh dear
have you ever been getting a massage and
then you get the happy ending
no see i've always heard about that too
you gotta know where to go i guess
oh i do know people who have had that
happen but in like japan
but you know that it's happening because
it's there's a menu i see yeah
they don't just start grabbing you maybe
if you just didn't know
it's one of those places could that
happen to my buddy i've heard of that
happening yeah so he was like man
my back is killing me i gotta go you
know i gotta get a massage
and then so he found a place on yelp and
then he went into
the uh spa and then he's like everyone's
getting massaged like in a big group
out in the public and he's like i'm kind
of shy
so let me get like a private room and he
asked them do you guys have any like
private rooms and they're like okay yeah
so then um while he was like changing in
a locker room
they busted out this folder and they're
like do you like any of these girls and
he's like yeah they're hot
and then they're like which one do you
like and goes which one's licensed
though
well he didn't make the connection that
it was one of those places because it
was like
people like families were getting
massage there like in the general room
you know how like when we go to those
places like whatever right yeah yeah so
he like looked at the yelp
uh yeah regular people look at the
comments
no i mean he was just saying that it was
highly reviewed yeah and then
it's just that i guess the whole uh
front of it was they did both he didn't
know
right and then so when he saw the girl's
pictures it just didn't connect in his
mind that they were gonna send
like a cute girl or anything like that
he just thought that the
guy in the locker room was like do you
like these girls do you think they're
hot he's like yeah buddy like he thought
it was one of those conversations
funny yeah he's like oh which one yeah
and then so he goes to the private room
the girl comes in
and he's like oh you're kind of cute
right you look familiar from a folder i
just saw
and then so basically she just did one
of these okay turn over
and then she started just touching his
dick and he's like oh what the hell
well i guess i can't stop now wow and
then after he finished he was like
uh can i actually get a massage because
my back hurts and then she's
laughed at him and he's like [ __ ] man
[Music]
so